DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don
Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today, we're going to talk
about open source and
specifically how startups
can use open source
to build their business.
My guest today is
Chris DiBona.
Chris runs the Open Source
Programs for Google.
Welcome, Chris.
CHRIS DIBONA: Hi, Don.
DON DODGE: So tell me
a little bit about--
you've been involved in open
source for a long, long time.
So tell me a little bit
about what you do.
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, I look after
open source for Google.
And we've talked about that
in a previous show.
But I've also been just involved
in companies that use
open source for--
since 1994, I guess.
It's when I was first exposed
to it personally and started
bringing it into my work.
So, yeah.
DON DODGE: Well, you
advise startups.
CHRIS DIBONA: I do.
DON DODGE: You invest
in startups.
CHRIS DIBONA: I do.
DON DODGE: You work with
Google Ventures.
CHRIS DIBONA: I do.
Yeah, so I've been doing
that for probably about
nine years, 10 years.
I had a startup myself that
failed miserably.
So maybe you shouldn't
take my advice.
But yeah.
So and obviously when people
want to talk to me, it's
oftentimes about how to use
open-source software and how
to use that in a developer
ecosystem, how to reach
developers, and that
kind of thing.
DON DODGE: So let's
give people a
little free advice here.
How can startups best
use open source?
CHRIS DIBONA: Well first of all,
if they're not using open
source, I would probably
not advise them.
And not because that's all I'm
good at but because I don't
have a lot of respect for people
who want to reinvent
the wheel that much.
Starting from scratch on
software seems very broken to
me when you can start with--
I mean, look at the Ruby on
Rails revolution and all those
web startups that came
out of that.
They didn't have to
start with Rails.
They could have just written a
bunch of PHP and started from
scratch with their own
templating and their own
database access libraries.
But they used Ruby
on Rails why?
Because it made things really,
really, really easy.
And they could be creative on
top of it first instead of
having to build all these
fundamentals and then be
creative and try to attract
a user base and the rest.
So when I talk to startups,
it's because they want to
continue to use open-source
software in an effective way.
Or they're at the point where
they want to release their own
software or bring developers
into their ecosystem.
And that's when I end up
talking to people.
DON DODGE: So you mentioned
Ruby on Rails.
That's interesting.
What are some of the other
foundational kinds of open
source that startups
should consider?
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, it depends
on when in time, when in the
dusty annals of time we're
talking about.
Because I mean, there were times
when people were making
a big jump over to open-source
databases, open-source
operating systems, open-source
languages, open-source
frameworks like Rails, and
open-source scripting
approaches.
I mean, there's so many things
that you would slap the open
source label onto and either use
or learn from or whatever.
And it's just fast.
It's like saying, which drop of
this ocean would you like
to speak about?
It's really interesting.
When people decide to start
releasing and trying to drive,
frankly, the direction of an
open-source project from
inside a startup or from inside
a company, that's also
something I'm pretty good at.
I've been doing it
for a long time.
When I was at VA Linux and VA
Research, and now at Google,
it's a fundamental part of what
I do is how do we drive
developer desire and developer
productivity towards these
platforms and ecosystems
around open source?
DON DODGE: So lots of
startups use Hadoop.
I talked to one yesterday
that uses Freebase.
There's MongoDB.
CHRIS DIBONA: Redis
and LevelDB and--
DON DODGE: So what are some of
the decisions you would make
on which way to go using
some of these things?
CHRIS DIBONA: So I usually start
with sort of the basics
of what's important
to the company now
and in the near future.
I don't want to sound too
conservative here, but a lot
of times people want to put the
scaling cart before the
user horse.
And they don't really think
through, OK, I have to have
users before I worry about
scaling to millions of them.
Or they want to plan ahead
for scaling that
will never, ever happen.
Or they don't really understand
a lot of the tools
that are out there that have
been around for a while,
things like MySQL
and Postgres.
You can scale them fairly
dramatically on modern
hardware before you're ever
going to see any sort of blips
that would even require you
to go to a master-slave
relationship, much less to a
NoSQL-style database where
you're going to lose a lot of
functionality in return for
what you think is scaling.
DON DODGE: And most startups
never get to
those scaling issues.
CHRIS DIBONA: Well, I mean,
I don't want to sound too
pessimistic, but yeah.
Most startups have a really hard
time attracting users,
much less scaling the
users they have.
That said, I mean, you don't
want to plan for failure.
You want to plan for
awesomeness and
hyper growth, right?
And so there are some things
you can do in the very
beginning to do that.
Like you can ensure that your
database queries are a certain
kind and aren't too many
left-handed joins or whatever.
But it really comes down to
understanding the fundamentals
that underpin your system.
It's funny, because a lot of
people talk about Twitter's
scaling problems in
the early days.
But if you think about it, they
scaled as well as they
needed to to grow
very quickly.
Right?
We made jokes about fail whales,
but you know what,
people were seeing them.
And that meant that people were
using the hell out of
that thing, right?
So yeah, it's embarrassing to
show that underbelly of your
company, that you failed
to scale today.
But at the same time, it's
good that you have that
problem is sort of the
long and short of it.
And the reality is, is by the
time that you have that
problem, there are people that
we know that we can bring in
and say, OK, you want to
scale MySQL for reals?
You want to scale Apache
for reals?
You want to start using
memcached for reals?
Well, here's who we're
going to talk to.
And here's who you're going
to want to have come in.
Or here's the kind of software
you're going to bring into the
company to make it
scale better.
It's funny, because if you
look at Wikipedia and
Livejournal and how they
scaled, it's extremely
instructive.
It's actually fairly shocking
how many people never really
looked at how these sites scaled
and instead went this
other direction, which was
incredibly computer intensive
and CPU intensive and machine
intensive, when they could
have just been much more
aggressive about caching.
People fail to understand how
little their databases are
changing from user view to user
view, for instance, and
how aggressively caches
can reduce the
draw on your machinery.
And then you get into these
side conversations.
Well, what happens when the
cache is empty and you
need to fill it?
And how can you pre-fill
caches?
And so we can have all
these discussions.
But it's pretty surprising to
me how little people have
learned from the scaling
lessons of the past.
And I'm not even talking about
the Slashdots and the circa
2000 or circa 2001.
I'm talking about things that
have happened in the last
couple of years and how little
they've learned about some of
the cloud providers and
their I/O performance.
DON DODGE: Where are
these lessons?
CHRIS DIBONA: They're
hard to find.
There are certain conferences,
I think, that are better than
others at exposing them.
But the thing is, if you go
to YouTube and you type in
"scaling my favorite website,"
whether your favorite website
is Twitter or Google or
whatever, there's somebody who
has given a talk at a Google
I/O or an OSCON or whatever
about exactly that topic.
Spend the 45 minutes during your
lunch hour, eat at your
desk or whatever, and learn.
There are so many great lessons
that are just waiting
there on YouTube.
I mean, really, you don't
even have to go
to a special website.
You can just go right there
and just type in "scaling
Twitter," "scaling this," and
you'll still see people
talking about exactly what they
encountered and what they
experienced and how
they did it.
Suppose you're using Rails.
You could say "scaling Rails."
Suppose you're using Drupal.
"Scaling Drupal." I mean, you'll
find these lessons.
They're out there.
You don't need a guy like me.
You don't need Brian Aker.
You don't need to go pay guys
like that, even though they're
great, to go and learn
these things.
But they've already told you.
DON DODGE: So just a Google
search or a YouTube search on
scaling Drupal or scaling--
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, and often
the code is right there.
You can copy it.
It's open source.
You can bring it over.
I mean, I think Brian's
Fitzpat--
sorry.
We joke about the wrong Fitz
inside the company.
Brad Fitzpatrick, who wrote
Livejournal and then memcached.
He's given the scaling memcached
and advances in
memcached talk at OSCON.
I think he gave it
for five years.
And the content certainly
changed and updated.
And it's different now than it
was the last time he gave it,
but not fundamentally.
I mean, the lessons are all
there for you to learn.
And it doesn't take a lot
of time to learn.
You can turn around in an
hour from right now.
You can shut off this podcast.
DON DODGE: Please don't.
CHRIS DIBONA: Don't.
And you could learn enough to
scale 2x, 10x, 100x, the
performance of MySQL, the
performance of Apache, the
performance of memcached, the
performance of Rails.
And we're talking in and out.
This is not a huge
amount of time.
You would have spent that long
re-watching "House Of Cards"
on Netflix.
DON DODGE: So literally, you can
find some experts giving
talks on scaling issues or using
open source issues on
YouTube or Google.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yes, exactly.
And you owe it to yourself
to do that
if you're in a startup.
Because startups, you have
all the great problems.
You have the problems
of getting users.
Once you get the users--
and there's lots of talks
on getting users.
I think you've given a talk on
how to become a startup.
It's like getting the users,
serving the users, and then
even monetizing, advertising.
Everything is out there.
Honestly, when I did
my startup--
and failed at it, I should
just point out.
This is the one I failed at.
It didn't fail because
of scaling.
of even attracting a
potential user base.
I had 25,000 people who
would have paid me
as soon as we launched.
It was failure to launch.
It was failure to execute
internally.
And so there's ample
opportunities to fail
independent of this knowledge.
But there's so much knowledge
out there now.
DON DODGE: Let's talk about
tools that are available to
help you manage your code or
manage open source and merging
it with your proprietary code.
CHRIS DIBONA: OK.
So we had talked earlier about
segregation of code so that
you know what you're using
and how you're using it.
There's tooling out there
that will help you track
open-source code and the rest.
But honestly, there's
not a lot you have
to worry about there.
If you're shipping software--
like you're writing an iOS app
or an Android Play app--
you'll want to be a little more
careful about the GPLs
and the share alike licenses
if you're not ready
to share your code.
But as far as tooling goes,
GitHub, code.google.com,
they're out there to help you
share and interact with these
outside communities already.
So what sort of tooling
do you mean, Don?
DON DODGE: Well, for example,
I've heard of startups that,
when they were in the process of
being acquired, discovered
open-source code they didn't
even know they had, because
some random developer employees
put open-source code
in there and didn't tell
them about it.
And they didn't discover
it until later.
CHRIS DIBONA: And that tends to
slow down acquisitions and
exits and the rest.
So again, just tell
your engineers.
And I've told tons of engineers
this in the
companies I've advised.
It's real simple.
If you bring software into the
company, if you're not being
creative in your brain and
typing it into the computer,
put it in the third
party directory.
Think about where that code
is coming from and
just keep it separate.
And then that's really
all you need.
If you're the kind of company
that ships software, well,
you're going to care about
if you're using
a share alike license.
If you're the kind of company
that ships on the web, you're
going to care about the ones
that really sort of want you
to pay instead of doing
that, the AGPLs.
So just a little bit
of foresight, and
it'll save some trouble.
DON DODGE: In the early days of
a startup, just eight or 10
guys hacking away and building
code, and you're not really
paying attention to having nice,
tidy code repositories
and keeping track of where you
picked up open-source code and
that kind of stuff.
CHRIS DIBONA: That
does happen.
Or they're not as complete as
we would want them to be in
our part of the world.
And that happens.
So the problem is it's like
everything in development.
You can do it now, or
you can do it later.
If you do it later, it's going
to take you 10, 100 times as
much work to do.
So to pull out a piece of
software that is running
inside your service before you
are acquired by another
company is going to take a vast
amount of work to replicate.
So you can do a couple
of things right now
as a software developer.
You just get in the habit of
dropping third-party code in a
third-party directory.
You can get in the habit of just
thinking through where
code comes from.
You can get the habit, frankly,
of learning from
places instead of just copying
the code if there's no license
apparent, as opposed to later
having to pull it out.
I've had to go back on
acquisitions and say, OK, if
you want to be purchased by
us, before we can give you
money, or before you can hit
a milestone, you have to
do x, y, and z.
And the look on--
actually, the non-engineer
face is always pretty
entertaining.
But the engineers are like, OK,
how am I going to do this?
OK.
And it's usually actually
really easy to do.
It's not hard.
Usually, with most open-source
packages, you're putting them
separate anyway, and
then you're calling
them in certain ways.
Or they're designed in such a
way that your code is very
clearly delineated
from their code.
But yeah, sometimes people are
like, wait, we could delay our
acquisition because of this?
We could delay our exit
because of this?
And it's like, yeah, you know,
because we have to respect
these people who have been so
generous as to give their time
and code to you.
All we have to do is be
a little courteous.
And that's the right
thing to do.
DON DODGE: So there are tools
like Black Duck software.
CHRIS DIBONA: Black
Duck, Palamida.
There's OpenLogic, which
is a nonprofit.
DON DODGE: So these tools will
review your source code and
find where there are open-source
segments and tell
you what licenses
you need to do.
So there are simple tools out
there that can help you.
CHRIS DIBONA: There's some very
simple tools out there.
We don't use Black Duck
here, Palamida here.
It's just, we're a
search company.
We're good at that
kind of thing.
They're fine.
Honestly, we've gotten to the
point now, at Google at least,
if we see the nature of your
startup, I can tell you what
software they're using.
It's video startups
use FFmpeg.
The use some of these
other libraries.
If you're some consumer
communications app, I know
what libraries you're using.
And it's not just me.
There's plenty of people
like me who are like,
OK, you're like this.
Or you could just buy that
expertise from the Palamidas
and the Black Ducks
and the rest.
DON DODGE: So let's talk about
another part of it.
Is it reasonable for a
startup to build a
viable open-source community?
CHRIS DIBONA: So yes and no.
What we see more often is an
open-source community that
becomes a startup.
You saw this--
I think, actually, Mongo
started this way.
I know that Drupal did and
Acquia, which is the Drupal
commercialization company.
Joomla was a little
bit of both.
I think they started-- they
wanted to do a CMS, but they
knew that to compete
in that market they
had to be open source.
So it just depends.
But yeah, I think fundamental
to having a developer
ecosystem around your product,
whether it's open source or
not, you're going to be using
open source examples.
If you look at how Google does
it, and we've done since the
very beginning, when we release
an example of code,
when you see a piece of code
in a Google blog, like the
Google Coder blog, you know
that license is there.
Even if it's just a snippet, we
say snippets are licensed
under the Apache license,
[? taxes ?] license under
Creative Commons
ShareAlike 3.0.
We say this at the bottom of
every blog, and we say this in
the About boxes, and we say
this all over the place,
because we want to have the
right relationship with our
developers.
We say, if you have this
software, here is the deal.
And I have to be honest with
you, one of the things that's
been happening lately around
hackathons and the rest, they
say if you take part in this
hackathon you're giving us all
of your patents, all the work
you're doing, all the
copyright, and the right to use
you in our marketing and
da da da da da.
And it's actually
deeply unfair.
DON DODGE: That sounds
kind of scary.
CHRIS DIBONA: It is scary.
It should really make people
pause and wait and look at
them, because it's come down
to there are some-- like
Googlers want to do
these hacker cups
and hackathons sometimes.
And I have to tell them no in
some of these cases unless
they change the terms
of the contest.
And what's funny about contests
and the way contest
law works in the United States,
if you structure it as
a contest, you have to give the
same rules to everybody
who takes part in it.
So you can't fix it
after the fact.
You have to fix it before the
contest starts and before
people start registering
for this contest.
So it's really a place where
every once in while, the
rapaciousness of the industry
will pop its head up and say
hey, I'm over here.
And you have to sort of have a
real eagle eye towards that.
Because people think nothing of
joining these hackathons.
And so what I try to do on
Google's side is make sure
that ours don't have those
kinds of stanzas in their
terms and conditions.
DON DODGE: And so if I'm
a hacker and I want to
participate in a hackathon,
what do I
need to look out for?
I've never seen this.
CHRIS DIBONA: Look out for terms
in the terms of services
of the hackathon that say all
the work of all participants
in this hackathon become the
property of or are given an
exclusive, and sometimes even
non-exclusive, right to all
patents and copyright
and all the rest.
You've seen these sorts of
agreements happen when people
try to do deals with big
companies, right?
It's like, sometimes you just
have to take it and
just stick with it.
But most the time, you should be
controlling your destiny a
little more carefully
than that.
And on behalf of our employees,
I have to.
So sometimes I have to give the
bad news that they can't
take part, which I hate doing.
Because I don't want to tell
somebody that thing you think
is for fun and for good and
computers science is not.
It's just nasty.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
I'd never heard that before.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah, so that's
something that's actually been
an emerging issue lately,
because hackathons have gotten
super popular over
the last year.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
Another recent issue, I read a
story this morning about crowd
funding of open-source
projects.
So sort of like Kickstarter
for capital applied to
open-source projects.
And it sort of blew my mind.
I had not seen that before.
CHRIS DIBONA: So we have, in
this world of open source,
back in 1997 there was a company
called Source Exchange
that tried this, where basically
they would have bug
bounties that would be directed
toward specific
improvements on open-source
software.
And then CollabNet, this was
their initial business model
before they switched over to
Version Control and the rest.
And then half a dozen
since then.
And I don't want to sound
negative on the idea, but by
the time open source wants
capital, wants money to drive
development, they either form a
company the way that Acquia
is for Drupal or whatever, or
companies will hire developers
directly to contribute.
I haven't seen crowd
funding that works
for open source yet.
And if you say, well,
what about the Ouya,
and what about this?
I would say, well, those were
actually hardcore products,
and they're using open source,
but they're not really
contributing to open source.
Or you say there's a
recent iteration
of PiDev, for instance.
And he's like, if I get
money I'll do this
and this and this.
And he says if he hits a certain
threshold, he'll make
it open source.
And it's like, well that
doesn't sound like
open source to me.
That sounds like you're funding
the development of a
specific kind of development
tool.
And maybe it'll be open source
if he hits 250,000.
It's like, so you hit
these sort of like--
open source is just the
sugar on the cake.
It's just this syntactic
sugar, as it were.
But it's not what it is.
And then I guess we had talked
about this earlier, and you'd
mentioned that there was like an
equity stake that was also
going to be proposed.
DON DODGE: Yes.
CHRIS DIBONA: And I have
to be honest with you.
As somebody involved in
startups, I can't see wanting
to dilute across 10,000 people
an equity stake.
People forget.
And I know the JOBS Act changed
a lot of things.
But the fundamental difficulty
of having a lot of
stakeholders is not to
be underestimated.
DON DODGE: Right.
CHRIS DIBONA: I mean, there's
a reason why companies avoid
going public for so long when
they're profitable.
It's a significant tax on the
company to have to report for
many, many shareholders.
And in fact, it's funny.
When people do go public, it's
because they have to do that
tracking anyways, because they
have too many shareholders.
So they might as well go public
since they're going to
have to be paying the price
anyway of having to share all
that information.
So I'm not as thrilled
with the idea.
I should read up more on this
most recent version of it.
But it's tough.
So you'll have to convince me
that it's going to work where
it hasn't worked before and that
the few models that have
worked for commercialization of
open-source communities and
open-source projects
that they've
stopped working somehow.
DON DODGE: So I think your point
is that if you have a
successful open-source project
that's attracting developers
and is becoming successful, then
you aren't going to have
a problem raising
money anyway.
CHRIS DIBONA: Exactly.
So I've never seen anyone
having problems from
[? name VCs, ?]
name whatever, getting
funding.
DON DODGE: And conversely, if
you don't have a successful
open-source project, the chances
of raising money
through a Kickstarter kind
of thing are pretty slim.
CHRIS DIBONA: Are lower, yes.
Now, it's funny about
Kickstarter.
And this will sound orthogonal,
but it's not, and
the success of self-publishing
novels on these digital
marketplaces, where
basically you're
cutting out a middleman.
So I think that there's probably
some knowledge to be
gained there.
Is there a situation in the
realm that we're talking about
that looks like the cutting
out of a middle man?
Maybe.
But I've always been deeply
suspicious of people who want
to be the middle man for
me to open source.
So we've been approached by lots
of people who say, what
we'll do is we'll take Google
money, and we'll make sure it
gets distributed to these
program groups or these
developers.
And I'm like, or we can
just cut them checks.
Why would we let you rip 5%,
10%, 30% off the top to give
us the pleasure of funding some
organization that's--
so I'm a little skeptical of
a Kickstarter model for
funding like that.
But I'm happy to be wrong.
If it creates more open-source
code, who cares?
DON DODGE: So the best advice
I heard from you in the past
10 minutes is if you're a
startup that wants to use open
source, do a search on Google
or YouTube for how to use it
or how to scale it,
and you can find a
lot of great advice.
CHRIS DIBONA: Or the
best warning ever.
A lot of people will say, if you
do this, you're going to
be screwed.
Don't do this.
And it usually won't affect what
you want to do with the
software at all.
It's just like, oh, if I go down
that road, I'm going to
have 10 times the queries, so
I don't want to do that.
DON DODGE: So even great
advice is free.
CHRIS DIBONA: Yeah.
It really is.
It's better than free.
It's really high-quality HD
streams from some of the
smartest people in
development.
And you can really buff up your
engineers in ways that
sending them to conferences
won't do and
sending them to training.
DON DODGE: Just watch YouTube.
CHRIS DIBONA: Just watch YouTube
for a little bit.
Have watching YouTube parties
during lunch or something.
I don't know.
DON DODGE: Interesting.
Well, that's another good
piece of advice.
If you're a startup, just watch
YouTube videos at lunch--
CHRIS DIBONA: It's
really true.
DON DODGE: --on how to do
things, and you can learn more
than a week at a conference.
CHRIS DIBONA: I would say that's
almost certainly true.
And conferences are a blast.
I love going to conferences.
I love speaking at them.
Well, most of them.
Not all of them.
We talked about that
earlier, too.
But I won't say that out loud.
But you're not going to go to
more than one, two conferences
a year, because you're murdering
a week of your life.
And that's 1/52 of your
productive time.
And then if you want a vacation
that's another.
So I mean, you're just chopping
away at the time you
have to spend on your
life's work.
Why would you want to do that?
DON DODGE: Well, thank you
for sharing with us.
CHRIS DIBONA: Thanks
for having me.
DON DODGE: This was terrific.
Thank you very much.
CHRIS DIBONA: Good
talking to you.
DON DODGE: And thank
you for joining us
on Google Root Access.
Join us again next week when
we'll talk about a topic of
interest to startups.
Thank you.